you know obviously West pasted were you
guys close did you talk to him in the
final years or any kind of conversations
or not really you know I didn't talk to
him in the final year of his life and I
think he had um you know he he too had
brain cancer and I I do think that he
probably deteriorated to a point where
his family protected him from too many
relationships it's just too exhausting
but um we would exchange a lot of emails
and so when he died we would talk once a
year probably um
but we always exchanged emails if he was
there and I'd say you know what are you
doing how are you doing I heard you you
know fell off your bike or know God well
he so he's so subtle and I remember on
set like him going you know we're
talking about horror movies and I'm like
am V he goes well you know that's not
real and I go yes it is he goes no it
was it was a hole just it was made up
I'm like no no it was not made up Wes
and we're taught in the rolling camera
like you can't say this to me before
rolling
Amar go yeah they they made it all up no
there's a ghost they took pictur anyway
he was so funny and he would always say
he was so he was so like Ry I mean he
was like oh yeah and he would have me
like it was the second time they were
filming this movie so you could tell
Christina reach she was nice but she
would she didn't want to be there nobody
want to be there I wanted to be there
and I was bummed no one else wanted to
be there right and you know I had a
small part was I just wanted to work
with Wes but each takey go uh do it like
Christopher Walkin do it like John
malovich do it like uh Jack Nicholson do
it like the guy from and I went to I
told the story but I went to the uh the
uh the premiere for the movie curst and
or no not the premiere the cast and crew
and they were showing
bloopers and it was all me and people
who the [__] are you I go I just I came
in for like three days and I'm like in
all the bloopers and like yeah it's
funny isn't it like but it was cool he
knew it was going to go on the blooper
reel he was just doing it for that Jesus